amnesty international a donc convié je
vous le disais serge babynes en france
dans les yvelines ce défenseur des
droits humains de 24 ans se bat face aux
violences perpétrées en tchétchénie il
se charge de collecter des informations
sur la violation des droits dans ce pays
et de les diffuser dans le reste du
monde
en fin d'après-midi il menait une
conférence débat à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
il sera aussi ce soir à 20h30 à
guyancourt à la ferme de bel ébat pour
engager la discussion autour de la pièce
comédie tchétchènes en représentation
sur ce site
nous l'avons rencontré il ya quelques
heures voici son témoignage au micro
d'anthony rech
évidemment j'espère beaucoup de mon
déplacement en france ce qui se passe en
russie est particulièrement tchétchénie
doit alerter les gens j'espère que ma
présence ici permettra d'améliorer la
situation
comme vous le savez la guerre est finie
en tchétchénie mais la situation reste
extrêmement dangereuse lorsque nous nous
rendons sur place
les dernières lois votées ont vraiment
pour but de détruire toutes les libertés
d'expression et les droits de l'homme je
ne vois pas d'avenir pour la russie